there's a reason that guys and gals like
me continue to have audiences because
people want to be motivated to go and do
things or they want to learn tactics to
go and do things but it whether I'm
giving you tactical advice like filters
on snapchat or Facebook ads or Instagram
story collaborations or I'm motivating
you through my words because I
communicate that way or through my
actions
seeing this wake up at 5:00 or if
everybody who's watching this actually
did something about it and then went on
the course of their version of it and
then they wouldn't be watching this and
I genuinely know at the bottom of my
heart out of all the people that want to
build audiences that I'm the complete
opposite of almost all of them because
99% of people that produce content like
this and are out there like I am the
business of being that is what they are
I have businesses I have wine library
and vaynermedia I don't need your 14
bucks for my book or to be in my course
or this and that so I don't need to
monetize you so I then genuinely want
you to never watch me again the problem
is every time you guys are posting the
only times I see on my on my Instagram
oh I needed this today and you know many
times I see that person nine months
later still hanging around if you needed
it then take it and do something about
it the reason there's gonna be a billion
motivational views today on YouTube is
that people love the feeling of being
motivated they don't like putting in the
work to do something about the feeling
I hate the motivation me
until you do something about
you